en el valle de la bekáa al noroeste de
líbano comienza la temporada de hachís
todos estos campos son cultivos de
cannabis durante 30 años el gobierno
había venido luchando contra estos
cultivos ilícitos que sostienen toda la
región pero en mayo en un intento por
estimular la tambaleante economía del
país el parlamento libanés votó a favor
de realizar el cannabis con fines
medicinales un cambio radical que los
aldeanos ven con desconfianza el norte
de la beca es una región pobre y aislada
donde las oportunidades son escasas el
cultivo de cannabis es una tradición que
se transmite de padre a hijo deje de
estudiar a los 13 años mi papá era pobre
cultivaba cannabis crecí en esos campos
con él no hay trabajo en la región
como muchos aquí este padre de familia
siempre ha vivido como un criminal
oculta su rostro porque acaba de salir
de la cárcel
la policía ya no nuestra casa y me metió
en la cárcel porque el cultivo cannabis
y ahora lo legalizaron de sal
hoy dice que quiere hacer todo lo que
esté a su alcance para volver a la
legalidad
salir de la cárcel y no encuentro
trabajo me gustaría retomar el negocio
del cannabis pero para hacerlo se
necesita tener un permiso y para tenerlo
no hay que tener antecedentes cómo van a
encontrar a un cultivador de cannabis
sin antecedentes este diputado participó
en la redacción de la ley de la
legalización afirma que con esta
decisión todos los habitantes de la beca
saldrán ganando
lo que me motivó a presentar esta ley
fue el deseo de liberar a los
agricultores de las garras de
traficantes de drogas y de establecer
una economía legal que les garantiza un
mejor ingreso a los agricultores y que
al mismo tiempo limite el tráfico
harden mojan de edad
líbano es el tercer productor mundial de
hachís
el cannabis terapéutico es mercadal
prometedor afirma el diputado
no podemos tener cifras precisas porque
es una actividad ilegal representa unos
800 900 millones de dólares al año y
creo que cuando legalicemos a esta
economía esas cifras podrían aumentar
los habitantes de la beca tienen sus
dudas este líder de la tribu local
siempre se ha negado a plantar cannabis
duda que su legalización sea buena para
los jóvenes de la zona
cuando la gente supo que el cannabis fue
legalizado empezaron a plantar en todas
partes son pequeños agricultores no
grandes traficantes si no encuentran un
comprador y el estado no lo compra
terminarán sufriendo grandes pérdidas
efe
[Aplausos]
de hecho la nueva ley prevé dejar que el
sector privado gobierne esta nueva
economía por el momento esto no se
aplica y siguen siendo los traficantes
como firas los que venden la producción
de los campesinos en los últimos años
los precios han caído muy bajo
en esta bolsa y 6 kilos y 250 gramos de
hachís el kilo cuesta 35 dólares
firas teme que la legalización resulte
en un colapso del precio del cannabis
en serio piensan que el cannabis va a
salvar la región que lo legalicen pero
que lo compren al precio actual de ser
así tal vez la gente pueda vivir del
cannabis pero si es para comprar el kilo
a 8 dólares van a matar el negocio y van
a matar a toda la clase de gente que
sobrevive gracias al cultivo del
cannabis
hay 48.000 órdenes de arresto emitidas
contra los fugitivos de la ubica ya sean
grandes traficantes como filas o
pequeños cultivadores
pasado la moto
la justicia me busca mis hijos vienen a
verme una vez por semana en lo profundo
de las montañas que primero nos preparen
una ley de amnistía y después si
podremos hablar de legalización y
proyectos de desarrollo para la región
la gente está cansada el negocio ya no
es rentable prefiero ganar menos pero
estar con mis hijos que será asesinado
por el estado y que mis hijos acaben
huérfanos
por el momento no se prevé una ley de
amnistía y el desarrollo de un verdadero
mercado para el cannabis terapéutico
está aún muy lejos el líbano con la
crisis como telón de fondo el
narcotráfico todavía tiene un buen
futuro por delante